si ce mois de mai est synonyme de
bonheur pour la plupart des salariés
pour l'établissement français du sang il
est plutôt source de stress comme ici
aux chaînés les produits sanguins
collectés ont une durée de vie limitée
le plasma peut se conserver un an mais
seulement 42 jours pour les globules
rouges et 5 jours pour les plaquettes
malgré la mobilisation des franciliens
depuis le début du mois à la situation
reste tendue
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que la
maladie elle elle ne fait pas le pont
elle ne prend pas de vacances qu'avec un
don de sang nous pouvons soigner trois
patients nous produisons un concentré de
globules rouges
nous produisons un plasma thérapeutique
et nous produisons également des
plaquettes grâce aux dons de sang et de
fait ces dons de sang sont essentielles
tous les jours de l'année en france dix
mille dons par jour sont nécessaires
pour répondre aux besoins des malades
pour effectuer ce geste qui peut sauver
des vies il n'est pas nécessaire de
prendre rendez vous il suffit d'être en
bonne santé
des trajets entre 18 et 70 ans et peser
plus de 50 kg compter deux heures
entretien prélèvements et collation
comprise
moi c'est assez naturel en fait de
donner son sens quand on est en bonne
santé pour pouvoir aider les autres
donc en fait j'ai attendu avec
impatience d'avoir 18 ans et de pouvoir
donner mon sang et maintenant j'en ai 19
et c'est la deuxième fois que j'aide mon
sens et je compte continuer encore
longtemps les l'excusent de la peur des
aiguilles bon je pense qu'après une fois
qu'on l'a fait on s'aperçoit que c'est
pas compliqué et puis c'est pour moi
c'est
ça fait partie du show ce qu'on devrait
faire sans se poser de questions dans
les yvelines il existe deux sites fixes
de prélèvement à poissy et aux chaînés
des collectes mobiles sont également
organisées régulièrement aux quatre
coins du département